400 trillion to one when you understand
that math how can't you live your life
that's how rare it is to be a human
being and what are you waiting for like
you've been given this ridiculous triple
Miracle like you're literally more
likely to win the lotto 10 times in your
life than actually have a life so I ask
you my friends with this one life you're
gonna sit on your couch and well you're
gonna be upset about some shortcoming
you're gonna be upset about that thing
that happened last week that you
up I'm asking you I'm promising you
please take this swing make this at bat
I am so tired of people stopping because
their Uncle critique that or their mom
made fun of them along the way or their
girlfriend doesn't think that they can
do it you've got one at that 400
trillion to one please do something
about it we're living through the
greatest era to be alive ever so please
please squeeze the of your one life